okay-y muhammad did you decide to come
out now to speak well first good morning
Betty and thank you for having me on and
second it's time for me to interact with
you and with others I've gone through a
last four months after 14 great years at
PIMCO
and I've now put together a portfolio of
part-time activities that I'm really
excited about and I'm also really
excited about being able to spend more
time with my family in my daughter so
you know things have been put in place
going forward and who else but you to
have my first interview with and I
appreciate a mom when you gave me the
call that you were ready I was of course
ecstatic that you were gonna join me for
your first interview and Muhammad are
you surprised about how big the news
became of your departure I was you know
I look back to my time at PIMCO and I
think wow what a great time I had the
privilege of working with the best of
the best in the industry I was there for
14 years including six years as the CEO
and the co CIO I have lots of friends I
value the acquaintances I value what we
did in terms of serving our clients what
we did in terms of globalizing the firm
in terms of diversity and inclusion in
terms of the pemko foundation but it was
time for me to do something different it
was time for me to step back and have a
different perspective on life and after
the long hours the grueling travel
schedule it just was the right time